welcome back to CBS this morning the
woman accused of helping alleged sex
trafficker Jeffrey Epstein recruit and
abuse underage girls is in jail this
morning
FBI agents arrested d'Alene Maxwell
yesterday nearly one year to the day
after Epstein was arrested she faces six
charges including illegally transporting
minors and perjury
Epstein killed himself in a Federal
Detention Center in New York City last
August while awaiting trial and Milegi
has been following the Epstein case for
a long time now mola good morning it's
been about 24 hours since this news
broke of ghilane Maxwell's arrest what
our apps team's accusers now saying
about it well Tony one woman I spoke
with says the word that keeps coming up
to describe this arrest is finally
finally you know for years ghilane
Maxwell has denied allegations that she
helped Jeffrey Epstein run his alleged
sex trafficking operation from right
here his Manhattan mansion among other
places
and despite detailed allegations against
Maxwell
she's never been charged until now the
FBI took d'Alene Maxwell into custody
Thursday morning at this home in New
Hampshire the indictment alleges Maxwell
helped Jeffrey Epstein recruit groom and
ultimately abuse underage girls
the youngest alleged victim was 14 many
of Epstein's accusers described her as
Epstein's chief lieutenant maria farmer
and sara ransom spoke to CBS News in the
last year elaine was Jeffrey's right
hand he made it very to what he wanted
that be punished
I saw Gillian going to get the women she
went to places like Central Park she
would say stop the car and she would
dash out and get a child
the indictment claims Maxwell in Epstein
would spend time building friendships
with minor victims taking them to the
movies or shopping Maxwell's presents
the documents claim helped put the
victims at ease during sexual
interactions with Epstein because an
adult woman was present it's definitely
a win in our book Epstein accuser
Michelle Licata believes even more
people deserve to be brought to justice
you're saying there are still a lot of
co-conspirators a lot of people who help
this sex trafficking operation function
they're still out there oh definitely
you can't have two people just doing all
the work there has to be people helping
them people helping them
prosecutors say Maxwell's relationship
with Epstein goes back decades
describing her as one of his closest
associates what is closure look like to
you in this case closure for me is the
Justice Department of the FBI if they
continue to go after the people that
were associated with them does knock
them out and let them know that what
they did it was wrong
sitting in a jail cell for the rest of
their lives would maybe teach them a
lesson
Oh Maxwell has long denied any
wrongdoing in her lawyer said no comment
regarding the arrest now another epstein
accuser virginia jew frey tweeted her
thanks to the FBI and the US Attorney's
Office in New York calling Maxwell an
insidious creature she says she hopes
the judge throws the book at her a
Maxwell is expected to be arraigned in
federal court here in New York next week
Tony all right molla thank you very much
Gail very interesting development here I
think a lot of people are wondering the
big question overall is what does
d'Alene Maxwell know about what Jeffrey
Epstein is alleged to have done well
listen you know Epstein's victims have
always been very adamant and unwavering
and there are accusations against her
it'll be interesting to see how this
turns out in court but on I know a lot
of people are relieved that she has been
arrested we shall see we shall see we
shall indeed yes indeed